dear friends
today we celebrate international women's
day
i want to start by saying thank you to
all the women and girls
who inspire us to shape a more equal
future
empower others so no one is left behind
and are leading the recovery from the
covet 19 pandemic
inspiration empowerment leadership
this is what defines women in europe and
beyond
europe needs your creativity and
entrepreneurial potential to lead the
fair
green and digital recovery of europe in
europe
41 of scientists and engineers are women
although we have reached 48 of female
phd graduates
women makes up only 33 percent of
researchers
and 22 percent of the head of higher
education institutions in europe
this needs to change it is clear that
without its talented and innovative
women
europe cannot and will not move forward
that is why today on international
women's day
i'm proud to announce women tech eu
a brand new initiative to support
women-led deep tech startups and give
them a boost
to grow their company into the deep tech
champions of tomorrow
at the same time i'm also proud to
celebrate
the closing of my year-long social media
campaign
eu women for future since the past
2020 international women's day i have
had the privilege
to showcase the remarkable achievements
of european women
in research innovation education
culture and sport and tough this
campaign is ending soon
we'll continue supporting and
recognizing talented women
who show us that nothing can stand in
the way
of girls committed to achieving their
dreams
allow me to guarantee you that i'm
determined to continue stepping up
the european efforts on women
empowerment
in particular i'm committed to ensuring
that the gender dimension
is fully integrated into the european
policy
for research innovation education
culture
and sport with horizon europe program
we reaffirm our commitment to gender
equality
in research and innovation for example
having a gender equality plan in place
will become an eligibility criterion
these measures are complementary to
those from
other programs within my portfolio such
as erasmus plus
with strong synergies with the european
universities alliances initiative
and the european institute of innovation
and technology
which will offer training in stem skills
to 40 000 girls
i would like to conclude calling upon
all of you
men and women of europe to join our new
women tech eu initiative sign up today
to become a mentor an inspiring
innovator
and business coach for talented european
women in tech
you girls and women have no limit
to what you can reach you know that you
can count on my full support
so that europe becomes your place
to develop your full potential let's
stay united
to continue to unlock the full potential
of women
for leading europe towards a green
digital healthy and resilient future
thank you